hey welcome back everyone to pay any
ferry - hey give me give me a leg oh
yeah let me inspect can you see anything
I had some burritos that way my eyes are
burning
I see mothers and black blood brothers a
pack stomp let's everybody time to
talked up the ass rockin can't commit
that one thing I really wanted to tell
you for a long long time what is it
I've had developed feelings for a very
long time for you and I wanted to say
that I know who are you gonna say no I
can't live like this
it happened yeah but I'm right did you
realize we have to play the game and it
makes me sad [ __ ] you [ __ ] the new rule
is that we both need to complete it
ok now the guys would take favor all
right
[ __ ] you you promise Kate hey human
sucker always promises grab that sack or
a jack oh good okay to be bullets nan if
to him
where's real sucks it's the rules main
rules rules rules is rules [ __ ] till
all right gotta live for 10 ken I'm not
leaving with oh I guess I am hit please
stay on the money how do you do that how
do i oh yeah leg dad are you getting
through the laser I bring a bring honour
to my family how do you bring through
the laser or you jump on it I get it you
know I'm trying to show you how to do it
cuz I'm so amazing
watch this watch me um
okay we take I do it yeah tell me how to
do it wait I can see that topping up
there yeah when it like when it's to the
right all the way jump up and you can
run through it all you're not stopped
and then the laser over there hey kill
you oh yeah you did it alright so I'm
not supposed to go left right what is
this [ __ ] no let's look at other things
uh there it is
hey did uh Betty Magana a reaming
panties
oh [ __ ] you in a dick hmm how do you
bought and what that watch this I'll
punch it yep ha jumped I made it
that's it jumped over I mean it even oh
it triggers when you walk on it don't
you damn [ __ ] I need something to fight
for damn it fight for freedom I'm - that
isn't bad on me Taco Bell a coke if we
don't have TAC apparently uh fight for
meatballs ah
you just sounded my memory I'm not even
your favorite real dad ah who told you
that
yeah I'd get him test cuz you look like
a [ __ ] red furry
did you get my blood from besides all
over the walls no I haven't even know
you broke the rule you know our rules is
rules yeah I love you daddy
and I would never hurt you oh ho ho go
ahead
daddy Sam oh my [ __ ] dick in the
[ __ ] ass oh the gun won't she though
girl like like if no one from the other
side no even shoot me it doesn't shoot
us on the starting spot so what should
you they're like the left gun that we go
past us and shoot us
I ran I ran all right a rat and that one
I rather eat you have to finish it oh
that was [ __ ] awesome I actually did
something in my life now I'm happy he's
not just out about my brat forever I'm
alright
yeah before you go I think you passed
now go oh gosh happening I don't know
what's going on hey hey buddy's been
dead